les paroles sont très dures c'était
volontaire ou pas ta part tu oui parce
qu'on m'a posé la question l'interview
et on me dit ouais tu dis quand même à
casser la gueule moi je dis ouais tu vas
dire quoi d'autre quand on se casse la
gueule on casse la gueule et moi c'est
mes mots j'ai un langage très simple et
j'essaie d'interpréter au mieux mais
quand tu casses la gueule on casse la
gueule quoi une fois tout à fait ce
titre aussi camille pour que et les
femmes qui qui se reconnaissent dans ses
paroles dures et kehl pour les pousser à
témoigner pour les poussins par les
autres moi je pousse personne à faire
quoi que ce soit c'est chaque histoire
est différente moi je connais bien le
sujet ça arrivait à pas mal de proches
c'est vrai que toutes ces histoires sont
différentes
après on ne peut pas dire à quelqu'un va
porter plainte fais comme tu peux déjà
pour te sentir bien et en sortir après
évidemment c'est un message quand ces
femmes-là qui s'en sont sortis je reçois
énormément énormément de messages a dû
recevoir énormément de bayssan armements
déjà quand la avance avant cette chanson
quand ceux des interviews sur sur ce
sujet dramatique on me disait tu en
parles hyper bien ses pairs juste moi
j'ai vécu ça j'ai réussi à m'en sortir
et puis en ce moment il ya des femmes
qui m'envoient des messages et qui me
disent je suis encore dedans c'est
horrible comment faire mais moi je leur
réponds fait comme vous pouvez me faites
attention à vous je suis personne pour
dire aller porter plainte même si ce
serait la meilleure chose à faire
évidemment c'est tellement violent et
c'est tellement dans un engrenage était
avec un bourreau qui te met plus bas que
terre et à ce moment là les gens ne
peuvent pas comprendre tour c'est très
très très violent c'est à dire que quand
on te dit tu es une merde tu y crois
parce que tu es lobotomisés est en
permanence on te dit tu es comme ça tu
fais ça je t'aime plus que tout le monde
autour et seulement ça arrive à des
femmes très très forte et leur but c'est
justement de te mettre plus bas que
terre et et quand on arrive la remontée
ces longs ont déjà une rupture classique
c'est très très long il ya déjà quand et
avec quelqu'un en relation de dire ok je
sais que je vais le quitter mais quand
c'est dur mais quelqu'un que tu aimes
mais qui te tapes tu dois le quitter
alors que tu l'aies mais en plus ils te
tape donc tu as peur pour la suite c'est
c'est très très complexe pour les gens
les abrutis 10ème et pourquoi tu pars
pas mais connard tu n'es pas dans cette
situation
tu ne peux pas savoir donc donc moi je
suis là pour ces femmes tous les jours